in the last video we saw how the
keynesian cross could help us visualize
an increase in government spending which
was a shift in our aggregate planned
expenditure line right over here and we
saw how the actual change the actual
increase in output if you are a if you
if you if you take all of the
assumptions that we took in this that
the actual change in output and
aggregate income was larger than the
change in government spending and so you
might say oh okay you know keynesian
thinking this is very left-wing this is
spending the government's growing larger
right here i'm more conservative i do
i'm not a believer in keynesian thinking
and the reality is you actually might be
whether you're on the right or left
although keynesian economics it tends to
be poopooed more by the the right and
embraced more by the left
most of the the mainstream
right policies especially in the us have
actually been very keynesian they just
haven't been by manipulating this
variable right over here for example
when people talk about expanding the
economy by lowering taxes they are a
keynesian when they say that because if
we were to rewind and we go back to our
original function so if we don't do this
if we go back to just having our g here
so if we if we go
back to just having our g so we're now
back on this orange line our original
planned expenditure you could based on
this model right over here also shifted
up by lowering taxes
if you
if you change your taxes to be taxes
minus
minus some delta in taxes
the reason why this is going to shift
the whole curve up is because you're
multiplying this whole thing you're
multiplying this whole thing by a
negative number by negative c1 c1 your
marginal propensity to consumer assuming
is positive you mult there's a negative
out here so when you multiply it by a
negative when you multiply a decrease by
a negative so this is a negative change
in taxes then this whole thing is going
to shift up again so you would actually
shift up
you would actually shift up in this case
and depending on what the actual
magnitude of the change in taxes are but
you would actually shift up and the
amount that you would shift up i don't
want to make my graph too messy so this
would be our new
aggregate planned expenditures but the
amount you would move up is by this
coefficient out here c
c one negative c1 times negative delta t
so your change the amount that you would
move up is negative
c1 times negative delta t if we assume
delta t is positive and so you actually
have a c1 delta t the negatives cancel
out so that's actually how much it would
actually move up and it's also keynesian
when you say if we increase taxes that
will lower aggregate output because if
you increase taxes if you increase taxes
you're the now all of a sudden this is a
positive this is a positive and then you
would shift the curve by that much and
so you would actually shift the curve
down and then you would get to a
you would actually get to a lower
equilibrium gdp so this really isn't a
difference between
right
right leaning fiscal policy or left for
leaning fiscal policy and everything
that i've talked about so far at the end
of the last video and this video really
has been fiscal policy this has been the
spending lever fiscal policy and this
right over here has been kind of the
taxing lever of fiscal policy if you
believe either of those can affect
aggregate output then you are
essentially subscribing to the keynesian
model now one thing that i did
touch on a little bit in the last video
is
whatever our change is however much we
shift this aggregate planned expenditure
curve the change in our the change in
our output actually was some multiple of
that and what i want to do now is to
actually show you mathematically that it
actually all works out that the multiple
is actually the multiplier so if we go
back to our original and this will just
get a little bit mathy right over here
so i'm just going to rewrite it all so
we have our planned expenditure just to
kind of re-re-dig our minds into the
actual into the actual expression the
planned expenditure is equal to the
marginal propensity to consume times
aggregate income
and then you're going to have all this
business right over here and we're just
going to go with the original one not
what i changed and all this business
let's just call that b that'll just make
it simple for us to manipulate this so
let's just call all of this business
right over here b we can substitute that
back in later we know we know that an
economy is in equilibrium when planned
expenditures is equal to output that is
an economy in equilibrium so let's set
this let's set planned expenditures
equal to
equal to aggregate output which is the
same thing as aggregate expenditures
with the same thing as aggregate income
and so now we can just solve for our
equilibrium income we can just solve for
it so you get
y is equal to c1 times y plus b this is
going to look very familiar to you in a
second subtract c1 times y from both
sides y minus c1y that's the left hand
side now on the right hand side
obviously if we subtract c1y it's going
to go away and then we have that is
equal to b
and then we can factor out
we can factor out the aggregate income
from this
so y times 1 minus c1 is equal to b and
then we divide both sides by 1 minus c1
1 minus c1 and we get that cancels out
we get i'll rewrite i'll write it right
over here we get
we get and now you get a little bit of a
drumroll
aggregate income our equilibrium
equilibrium aggregate income aggregate
output aggregate aggregate
gdp is going to be equal to is going to
be equal to l to 6 1 over 1 minus c 1
times b remember b was all this business
up here
now what was one what is what is this
you might remember this or if you
haven't seen the video you might want to
watch the video on the multiplier this
c1 right over here is our marginal
propensity to consume
marginal propensity to consume one minus
our marginal propensity to consume is
actually and i don't think i've actually
referred to it before actually let me
rewrite it here just so you know the the
term
so c1 is equal to our marginal
propensity
is equal to our marginal propensity to
consume so for example if this is if
this is 30 or 0.3 that means for every
incremental dollar of disposable income
i get i want to spend 30 cents of it now
1 minus c1
1 minus c1 you could view this as your
marginal propensity to save
if i'm going to spend 30 then that means
i'm going to save 70 so this is just
saying i'm going to save 1 minus e1 if
if i'm spending 30 of that incremental
disposable dollar then i'm going to save
70 of it so this whole thing so this is
a marginal propensity to consume this
whole this entire denominator is a
marginal propensity to save and then 1
over that and so 1 over 1
minus c1 which is the same thing as 1
over the marginal propensity to save
that is the multiplier we saw that a few
videos ago if you take this infinite
geometric series if we just think
through how money spends if i spend some
money on on some good or service the
person who has that that money is income
is going to spend some fraction of it
based on their marginal propensity to
consume and we're assuming that it's
constant throughout the economy at all
income levels for this model right over
here
and then they'll spend some of it and
then the person that they spend the
money on they're going to spend some
fraction when you keep adding all of
that infinite series up you actually get
this multiplier right over here so this
is equal to
this is equal to our
equal to our multiplier so for example
if b gets shifted up if b gets shifted
up by any amount let's say b gets
shifted up
and it could get shifted up by changes
in any of this stuff right over here and
that exports can change planned
investment can change it could be
shifted up or down the impact on the
impact on gdp is going to be whatever
that shift is times the multiplier times
the multiplier we saw it before if for
example if for example if c1 is equal to
is equal to 0.6
then that means that for every
incremental
disposable dollar people will spend
sixty percent of it that means that the
marginal propensity to save
for to save is equal to forty percent
they're going to save forty percent of
any incremental disposable dollar and
then the multiplier
the multiplier
is going to be 1 over that it's going to
be 1 over 0.4 which is the same thing as
1 over 2 fifths which is the same thing
as 5 halves which is the same thing as
2.5 so for example in this situation we
just saw that
that y the equilibrium y is going to be
2.5 times whatever all of this other
business is so if we change b
by let's say a billion dollars and maybe
we change maybe we we we if we increase
b by a billion dollars we might increase
b by a billion dollars by increasing
government spending by a billion dollars
or maybe having this whole term this
whole term including the negative right
over here become less negative by a
billion dollars maybe we have plan
investment increase by a billion dollars
and that could actually be done a little
bit with tax policy too by letting
companies maybe depreciate their assets
faster if we can increase net exports by
a billion dollars essentially any way
that we increase b by a billion dollars
that'll increase gdp by 2.5 billion
dollars 2.5 times our change in b
so we could write this down
this way our change in y
our change in y
is going to be 2.5 times our change in b
or another way to think about when you
write the expression like this you see
if you said y is a function of b then
you would say look the slope is 2.5 so
change in y
over change in b is equal to 2.5 but i
just wanted to write this to show you
that this isn't some magical voodoo what
we're doing this is what we looked at
visually when we look at the keynesian
cross but this is really just described
describing the same multiplier effect
that we saw in previous videos and where
we actually derived the actual
multiplier